Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
Well, let's see, I started in the ICU in 2016.
There was a few years of drowning in the education and all the things that we do in the ICU.
As I got more, I think, a theme I was thinking of before I came over, it was the concept
of fake it till you make it.
That point it seemed like I was pretty confident in what I was doing.
Even though internally I didn't feel that way.
I think one of my coworkers at the time was like, yeah, I've been flying for a couple
of years.
You should start flying.
I was like, oh, you think I'm ready for that?
Then she was like, yeah, you should apply.
Here's the application.
I'm like, okay.
I started flying for a fix-me company.
It was all PRN at the time, which was cool for me because I was working full time in
the ICU.
Then I would have my extra days of being on call.
Whether we did something or not, you get paid while you're home.
That was pretty sweet.
I always knew that I wanted to go into flight.
When I got into nursing school, it was like, okay, eventually I'm going to do flight.
I worked there for four years or so before I came to Air Mythids.
The last year, it's completely different from what I was doing before in a good way,
I think.
To answer your question more shortly, I always knew I wanted to fly.
That's always been a goal.
The hospital you're working at, you were in an ICU and as a trauma surgical ICU, right
on.
Yeah, you know what that's like.
We do everything.
Yeah.
I had some background for everyone.
Morgan and I worked together in the ICU and now we work at the same base for CareFlight
here in Santa Fe.
Yeah.
Up there in Santa Fe.
I guess we're in Alberts.
Yeah.
How has it been the transition from bedside nursing into like fix-me flight and then into
rotor?
I think that's a question that a lot of people have when they're considering whether they
want to get into this whole scene in general.
Yeah.
I think it was pretty similar to starting out in a sub-acute floor and going to an ICU,
like a busy ICU where you have these expectations and there's things that you're expected to
know and do in the ICU, kind of similar to me in that sense going from fixed-wing to
rotor.
It was like, okay, now you've learned some things here, apply that and then add on top
of all of the other aeromedical stuff, aeronautical stuff, flight physiology and logistics that
you just don't see in an ICU or in a hospital or space.
The pre-hospital stuff is, it was quite overwhelming for me at first.
Yeah.
And also like the different patient populations.
In the nursing side, we tend to be pigeonholed into one specific patient set.
In our ICU, we never see kids.
We rarely see kids.
Right.
Yeah.
Definitely not babies.
Or pregnant women.
And I remember like a few times where you get a younger kid that comes into the ICU
or pregnant woman or post hemorrhage or whatever.
It's like, well, what do you mean?
Like, I don't know what I'm doing here.
Yeah, for sure.
So yeah, I think that aspect has been challenging for sure in a rotor setting.
You're still getting fed information with a fire hose.
It's only been a little over a year for me in that arena.
So it still feels pretty.
It can feel overwhelming sometimes.
Currently, I just got through a bunch of quarterly innovations and quarterly stuff
that we have to do.
It's like stressing to get that done before the 20th while studying for my CFRN.
So when you test.
Next month.
Nice.
Yeah.
So I'm not looking forward to it.
But it's a necessary evil in the process.
It's weird to do like a certification that your job requires you to have.
So there's this like added pressure of like, yeah, if I fail again, then I lose my job.
Like, that sucks.
Yeah.
Because I guess normally you would like get the certification first.
So it's behind you before you transition into the job.
Yeah.
Huh.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Did you have your CFRN before you started flying?
I did.
Well, I kind of went about it in a different way because I flew as a medic first.
Yeah.
So I had my FPC already before I got my nursing degree.
And at the time we had a different like transition process for medics to become nurses.
So I was a nurse and was working in both the ER and ICU.
But I was still getting paid in flight as a medic.
So kind of in protest.
I just took all my Vans certs and was like, you guys should pay me more.
Yeah.
And they were like, no.
And I was like, cool.
I'm going to leave.
And then let me come back eventually.
But yeah, that's why I did it that way.
I thought maybe I could, you know, shift the seas of which I come through if I like, yeah,
stronger of them and with all my pieces of paper, but they're very sad in their ways.
Yeah.
But yeah, that's okay.
They let me come back eventually.
So it's fine.
Well, you know, and I think in that just hearing your story about it, it seems compared to
where I'm at right now, like mentally, I'm like freaking out about this, you know, this
certification.
Like I failed once already.
I'm re-studying, you know, doing it again.
And I'm going to retest.
Where you were like, you had your FPC, like you just went to nurses.
People were like, well, I'm just going to take this test now.
Yeah, it's safe stuff.
Yeah.
And I think I'm also pretty lucky in that, that I've always done pretty well at taking
tests.
Like that's, I recognize that is not the case for a lot of people.
Sure.
So yeah, I think maybe I had an unfair advantage in that.
Yeah.
I mean, this is what it is, right?
Yeah, totally.
Everybody has their own thing.
Yeah.
I've always struggled taking tests.
It's just who I am.
Yeah.
You'll figure it out.
I'm not worried.
Yeah.
And then another question I had for you is like, you did all of your nursing time in
like the inpatient side.
Do you, how do you think about like in hindsight, do you think there's value in getting ER experience
as well?
So like most people come to flight either with ER experience or ICU experience.
Occasionally we see people have both, but normally like most nurses like follow one
track or the other.
What are your thoughts on that?
I think it would depend on where you're at.
I've talked to a few people recently that, you know, work full time in the ER and don't
really have a lot of experience with titrating trips or, or, you know, using multiple drips
to get a certain effect or a certain outcome.
I think it would be pretty helpful to have more experience with pediatrics.
Because that's always like a source of contention with, with people in general.
I think like the universal thought is, Peds are just challenging in general.
Yeah.
Kids are scary.
Sure.
I personally like had I thought about that ahead of time, like I probably would have
tried to do some more time in, in pediatrics, not so much in like NICU specific or, you
know, working in the ER in the hopes that I would get some Peds here and there, but
like actually like go work in the PICU, go work in the Peds ED.
Yeah.
You know, that I think would be beneficial.
I think a hospital like UNM where they have a dedicated PDR is an available option.
Right.
Now the flip side of that though, I think is, does it really matter?
No.
For sure.
Yeah.
That's one thing I don't know if we ever had this conversation when you were like looking
to come fly, is it like all you have to do is I'm like oversimplifying here, but like
to get into a flight program is you have to demonstrate that you're like not an asshole
and that you're trainable.
Like, and then you get along with people and they will teach you the things that you
don't know yet.
So like expecting people to know how to operate in an aircraft when they never done it is,
is unfair.
Like expecting someone to know how to like take care of like a sick OB patient or a kid
and they never done it.
And that's, that's unrealistic.
So yeah, I think.
And also, I mean, even when you train, you know, and I think we're going to get to this,
I got lucky, I think in that I had a lot of time to train in a rotor, like during my orientation.
Yeah.
But like some people don't get that at all.
Like they're training on fixed wing and then they're coming to a rotor base and they're
like, well, I've never even flown in a helicopter.
Like how do you expect me to work now?
Yeah, that's how it was for me.
Because when I started here, we didn't have any, we only had eight stars in the state.
So all of my orientation was a fixed wing.
And then like your first rotor shift is like the first time you're like putting on your
helmet in the GZ going to a scene flight.
And like, I was lucky that I had some background in like the side, but I can't imagine like
coming into that scene, like not having done that, like trying to manage your first scene.
Yeah.
Without.
And that's, I think that's what I came to realize is like the more challenging part
of, of air medical is, is like the, the stuff that you just have no exposure to.
Right?
Like, like when I went on my first scene call, luckily I was with somebody that knew what
they were doing.
Cause I was just like this lost puppy, like wandering around like, yeah, I can carry that.
I can do that.
Or like, sure.
Sure.
Yeah.
Like whatever totally just like running around, not really being efficient in any way.
But I think it's also worth remembering that like, that's fine.
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
I think like we tend to have this perception, like we as like Brownian as people and like
nurse in the hospital that like the flight crew is like, yeah, they're on it all the
time.
Yeah.
Now they just wear cool pajamas.
That's it.
Yeah.
No, it has been an interesting experience to see that firsthand too, where, you know,
I walk into a room and I'm like, you know, shitting my pants, but what we're about to
do and like, what's going to happen and everybody's looking at you like, okay, what's next?
I don't know.
Yeah.
And sometimes you just got to like do something or like convince everything to everyone else
to do nothing, you know, just like make a decision one way or the other.
Yeah.
You don't necessarily have to do stuff, but like voice a decision and it's probably going
to be fine.
So then like going back to this, you know, fake it till you make it concept, right?
I think it's so, um, it's very useful and it can be pretty prevalent in critical care
space in general.
Um, and it does help.
It totally helped me get from where I was to where I am.
And in the process, like I still struggle with like imposter syndrome, you know, like
there's a lot that I know and there's a whole lot that I don't know.
Yeah.
And so then being able to recognize that and have the humility to be like, well, let's
confer with someone else.
Like let's get some help from someone else or, you know, figure that out.
I think is still a pretty key attribute to have.
Yeah.
And I think that's, I think that's normal.
Like yeah.
I think if you ever get to a situation where you're not ever, you never have any doubt
about what you're doing, like probably just not looking hard enough.
Yeah, for sure.
Um, so yeah, I think like that is a healthy response because you don't want to be overconfident
in what you're doing.
Yeah.
And it's been for me, like I've been flying for a long time now.
Like I started flying in like 2013.
Um, and like, I forgot the blood at the base the other day, going on a seed flight, right?
It's like, yeah, it happens.
Like you make mistakes and it's like part of the game.
Yeah.
Um, but then owning it totally owning it is the, for sure.
And yeah, we had to like, yeah, we figured it out and it was fine.
Yeah.
And it was like, I flew out blood for a long time.
But does make you feel really silly and that's okay.
Like that's part of it.
Yeah.
Um, if everything was easy, like the appeal of the job, like would be different.
I think my, my clinical director, you know, knows be by name and kind of when I'm on shift,
oh, usually expects a call early morning or after shift to have some sort of conversation
or explanation of something I did different or wrong or whatever.
Um, and that's totally fine.
Not that I'm like a terrible clinician, which is what it kind of making myself up to be.
But they, if you were terrible, you probably wouldn't still be working here.
So, yeah.
Um, so yeah, I think, I think it's natural to get into the flight world with the skills
you have and then develop as you go.
For sure.
Yeah.
Totally makes sense.
So having made it through, um, this, I guess you could call it like a prolonged transition
period from like bedside nursing into flight.
Um, you've kind of started a project to help other people navigate this transition as well.
You want to talk about that a bit?
Yeah.
So, um, I started a school group.
Are you familiar with school?
Only through your project.
So it's a pretty cool application.
It was developed by some, some guys that wanted to, uh, combine creating a community with
monetizing it somehow.
Um, and so they've done all the, like the back end work on, um, the pages and the applications
that you can set up, setting up links and all of that.
And so it was pretty easy to set up, but the overall goal really for me was, um, I think
coming out of working in the ICU, you know, you, you work with a set of people pretty
much consistently.
You're training people daily, um, educating yourself and educating them.
I always felt like the best way for me to learn thing is to try and learn it and then
teach it to someone else.
And I think, I think UNM is pretty pro that just being like the, at the teaching hospital
that it is, you're expected to like train people like right off orientation essentially.
And so then not having that kind of community or, um, space where, where I'm teaching someone
else something.
Um, and also, I mean, you know, the guys at the base we've all been there, you guys are
all really knowledgeable.
And so it's, it's really been cool to learn from you guys about it.
Um, and, but also then have a space where people can come, you know, talk about their
struggles, talk about, you know, cases that were challenging.
Cause sometimes you go through a situation and then you come out the other side, like
what really happened there?
Like I'm not really sure how we got from where we were to where we went and what we
did in between.
Um, sort of like bring those cases, bring those, um, you know, challenging situations
or scenarios and get a different perspective.
Cause that has always really helped me for sure.
Um, so that's really been the goal for me to, to create a space that people can do that
in.
Um, and it's been pretty cool.
And there's, there's some new people, um, that I think are, are hopefully getting some
benefit out of the group.
Um, there's a lot of experience like, you know, you're in there, it's, you've got a
ton of experience.
This, you know, Derek grassley, he's been there for awhile and, um, he's always posting
like new and maybe not new things, but like things that I didn't really ever think to
do.
So being able to pool that kind of knowledge and, and make it a safe space to, to share
kind of what we're dealing with.
For sure.
That's, that's been, yeah.
And particularly with our program, like kind of, it's like a pretty like distinct difference
between like clinician and educator.
We don't, there are some exceptions there, but for the most part we tend to like separate
that, which is very different from how it's done at the hospital we came from.
Yeah.
But yeah, that was kind of a similar motivation for me starting this whole project was like
having a platform to like, yeah, like iron out those details about complicated things
or like trying to explain something that you think you know, and then you like go to write
it down or like make a video on it.
And you're like, wait a second.
Yeah.
This is not, this is not coming out how I thought it would.
Maybe I don't know this as well as I did or as I thought I did.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Well, and that's a cool, I think it, it takes humility and awareness, right?
To look at something and be like, oh yeah, I know this.
And then start to talk about it.
You're like, wait a second.
Like this isn't, I don't think this is actually right.
Totally.
But to have then a sounding board, like someone to talk to some, some group of people to bring
that to and be like, does anybody else have any other experience with this?
That's always been a big proponent or I've been a big proponent for that, but also then
taking that information and like, oh yeah, okay.
So I can learn something from it.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's cool.
And you also have like a, you should call it a social media presence that accompanies
that.
Yeah.
With the, really the school group is the platform that I'm sending people to through the Instagram
page.
And the Instagram page is more of like the marketing side of it, I would say.
And so I've been learning how to make reels and kind of try and make them interesting,
catch people's attention.
And then they start to, like hopefully then they're scrolling through the comments or
the commentary and getting the link to the school group.
Yeah.
I think for my project, it's been a little different, but I definitely have learned how
to do a lot of things on like the tech side that I wouldn't have ever learned before.
Like I mean the podcast thing, like managing RSS feed, like editing videos and like making
graphics on the computer.
It's been kind of cool.
There's nothing else just for like developing that skillset.
Yeah.
Which is funny now because like, you know, like some people, they can do the things that
take me like hours to do and they just like happened so fast because they grew up doing
that.
Yeah.
Makes me feel like a little bit old.
But yeah, it's been cool to learn.
Yeah.
No, I feel the same.
I'm getting better at it now, but like when I first started it, it would take me like
an hour or something to like make one real.
Totally.
And yeah, so now it's getting faster.
Yeah.
Then you start, I'm starting to like struggle with ideas like, oh, what am I going to talk
about now?
Yeah.
And that's definitely like something very different between like how you do your social
media stuff and I do because you've kind of like set a goal to like post things every
day where I post like sometimes like I have time in a week and I post a couple of times
and sometimes it's like months between things.
Yeah.
It's like radio silence for a while.
But yeah, I've never felt that pressure to like come up with ideas because I just have
like a continual backlog on my phone.
Like, okay, someday when I have time, I'll do these things.
Nice.
But yeah, that's interesting.
Yeah.
The research and stuff that I've put into learning how to be a better social media,
you know, influencer or video maker or whatever, you know, the algorithm has its own brain
and you really have to do things in a certain way to make the algorithm push your stuff
out.
Interesting.
Because otherwise, you can you just posting when you want to and not that that's bad.
Like that's yeah, it was like a different mode.
Yeah, for sure.
Right.
But I have found like a this is the this is the third social media page that I've started.
And like my other one died because I wasn't posting enough.
So there's like, you know, there's like 10 followers and it doesn't ever grow.
But somehow, you know, in then you start to get into this, like, okay, at what point
do I do I take quality over quantity?
For sure.
Because I'm just trying to post three reels a day.
That can be challenging in itself to have enough stuff to enough media to post and things
to talk about.
But but yeah, at some point, I think I'm going to have to switch more to like a person or
an in person presence for sure.
And then have more quality stuff than just quality.
Yeah.
And I found like from my stuff, a lot of the value that I get back out of it is just in
like messages and comments on stuff like the dialogue that comes from whatever you're doing
to get people's attention.
Yeah.
Like maybe someone doesn't actually like care to read the whole thing you posted, but they
like the idea or they like picked out a picture that they recognize or something like that.
Yeah.
And they like reach out about it.
So I think that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
No.
And I do like the like I made a real it's been a few weeks now.
And in the moment, it was just something to get out there.
Like it's literally they has no value to me whatsoever.
Like it's literally me like turning the monitor on and off.
And then I said something like I because I haven't before flight and never used the
sole monitor.
And I was like, sometimes I miss the Philips bedside monitor because you can take a blood
pressure and it's exactly what you think it's going to be.
You know that that's the correct value.
You know, in a helicopter, it's not that way sometimes.
And so many people have been talking about that.
That one year, it's got like 50,000 views and you're sharing it.
Oh, wow.
This holds no clinical values at all.
Like it's kind of interesting what whether it's the algorithm or whether it's like people,
I don't know.
But yeah, I had a video that I made like a couple years back and it was just like, you
know, there's like different like one person techniques you can do for a bougie where you
like flip it around and like, yeah, like I did a video and I posted on Instagram and
got like, I don't know, like handful of views, a couple, I don't know.
I was like viewed like a couple thousand times.
But a few months ago, somebody sent me my video and someone it was like, this like metal
music track over top of it.
And I had like hundreds of thousands of views on TikTok.
And I was like, what the fuck?
How does that happen?
Yeah, I mean, it's I think it's partly the algorithm.
I think it's partly, you know, what what people are sharing at the time.
Yeah, for sure.
But but yeah, it's it's been a fun.
It's been a fun project and a fun thing to learn about kind of on the side.
Yeah.
I'm not sure what the sound is there.
What is the instruction?
Yeah, what's the the hope with it?
Are you you mentioned that you maybe have to like change your strategy or eventually
like, what do you do you see it going?
Yeah, I mean, right now, I think it's kind of in its infancy, trying to just create followers
and learn kind of where I'm going with it.
Most of my stuff that I put out right now is kind of on, you know, like the mental aspect
of nursing and flight, just because that's where I'm at, I think.
So I think it will change as I as I change.
You mean like, just working in the setting in general, like working in health care?
Working in health care and also like, you know, we have a challenging job, like we do
a lot of things.
I'm made aware most of the days that I'm home, that not a lot of people can do the job we
do.
I sure my wife hates hearing about the stories that I have.
And she like doesn't want to listen to me doesn't want to like, have a conversation about them.
And like, when I go out and people ask what I do, and I say I'm a flight nurse, and they're
like, Oh my God, like, how do you do that?
So anyway, the point I think is that we have a challenging job.
And it is good to recognize that.
Because it's, it's easy to get burnt out.
I mean, the burnout rate for clinicians is something like 65%.
We're always in a nursing shortage.
We're always in a provider shortage.
You know, there's, there's more people leaving health care than there are coming in.
And so I think it's, I think it's cool and useful to build awareness for and also share
some of the tips and tricks and things that I've learned along the way that hopefully
benefit other people.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, and I think some of that does like crossover to the general population, but definitely
is like more apparent for folks in our field, like just the cumulative exposure to like
shitty fucked up things is definitely above average.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, in the ICU two versus in critical care, it's one of the highest assault areas
in the world in the country.
Yeah, probably in the world.
I don't know that statistic, but in the country for sure.
And yeah, it's shitty and we still choose to do it anyway.
So yeah.
Moving on to something less sad.
Transitioning into flight, what is your favorite part about working in flight like the
lifestyle that affords you?
Well, I mean, the the days off for sure are awesome.
I don't think I know of anywhere that you can work two days a week.
Yeah, it's pretty rad.
So that's pretty sweet.
And.
Sorry, what was the question where like, what do you like transition to flight?
It's very distracted.
It is very distracted.
I have really enjoyed the.
The scene call and like.
Getting to I mean, getting to fly around a helicopter is just like, yeah, super.
It's super fun.
But then like.
You know, like one of my favorite things about working in the ICU was when I would recover
an open heart patient and it would just be me in a room with this critically ill patient
managing all the drips, managing all the chest tubes and outputs and, you know, finding
things that could go wrong and preventing them from happening along the same lines in
flight. You're doing the same thing except with way less information.
Totally.
Like you show up to a place and you have no idea what this person's background is, what
they do on their free time and you have to figure out how to get them from point A to
point B as stable as possible and work with another human being to do that.
And there's just a lot of different variables that go into that.
But like that part has been really challenging and enjoying that challenge has been
cool for me to see in myself.
You like learn this other person's way of communicating and thought process and you can
then start to like, you know, just start doing things and they're right there backing you
up or doing the same thing on their end or whatever.
It's like this weird little.
I don't know, micro micro microcosm of like things that you're all just like compiling
together to like for sure for one one immediate goal.
Yeah. And on a time crunch.
And on a time crunch.
Yeah, that's cool.
Yeah, I particularly like that aspect of it.
But also it sneaks up on you.
You know, like most of the flights we do are pretty routine.
All of a sudden you're like sleeping in your cozy bed at two o'clock in the morning and
then you get woken up and you're expected to perform in coordination with your other with
your partner clinician at like a very high level.
Like I like that challenge of going from just like baseline chilling the base or sleeping
like having to be on it right away.
I think that's really cool.
That's something we don't get in the hospital side so much.
Like we get very, very sick patients in our ICU.
But you have time.
You know, you can prep, you can look through the chart, like you can figure out the story
before you get all your shit set up.
So you're like ready to go.
You're like, I got this.
I know ahead of time before they get here that I got it.
Yeah, you don't have time to do that in flight, which is cool.
But you still have to do it.
Yeah.
I think that's really neat.
The other thing that I think has been particularly interesting for me is like I'm a planner.
Like I like to plan things out.
I like to know ahead of time.
So like, you know, I definitely have that ICU brain where I'm like, all right, I can, I can prep for all these things.
But not having that information ahead of time has forced me to like think about things that could go wrong.
Totally.
And then, okay, then what things am I going to need in a pinch?
Yeah.
And so that has been really interesting and challenging for me to adapt to.
But still kind of along the same lines.
Yeah.
Well, I think that's all the questions I had.
Okay.
For you.
Yeah.
Um, I wanted to ask about, so you have been flying, you said for since 13, 2013.
But not consistently the whole time.
I'd like come and gone a couple of times, but like the majority of the last like 11 or 12 years.
Yeah.
Cool.
You have, um, you've been able to kind of do a lot of different things within the same kind of context of, um, being a medic, being a nurse, being in critical care.
And so I was curious about how you got into DMAT and you know what that is.
Yeah.
So the, uh, DMAT is a disaster medical assistance team.
So basically the federal government has a number of teams that respond in a medical capacity to disasters, mostly here in the US, but every once in a blue moon, a team will get sent overseas.
Um, and yeah, I first learned about, um, the whole DMAT program.
I took a class years ago when I first moved out to New Mexico, so it was like over 10 years ago.
I took a class up in Seattle with this group called, uh, remote medical international.
They used to do this class.
Um, that was called remote medicine for the advanced provider.
So it was for like medics, nurses, mid-levels, physicians to like kind of teach you how to operate as a, like an expedition lead in an outdoor setting.
Yeah.
And one of the guys who was in my class, he was a medic with, um,
So is that kind of, is that kind of similar to search or rescue?
A little bit different in that the, this particular class was more for like, let's say you're going on like a back country trip or you're hired as a medical provider for an expedition.
Like you, like how to plan for that in general, like which equipment to bring from the front country to the back country.
Um, how to improvise the things that you ought to be improvising, how to like know when like you should just take the piece of equipment and not improvise.
How to decide which medications to take all of that.
Um, so more like on the planning and logistics side of that versus like surgeon rescue, where like someone's lost in like kind of like in our situation where you just like go on a call out basis to find them.
But anyways, one of the medics in that class, he was a, uh, King County medic one paramedic and he was on the Washington state DMAT team and he mentioned it to me.
So at the time I reached out to try to like find something about our DMAT here in New Mexico because I, you know, through searching on the Google's, I found out that we had a team.
It turns out that, uh, Kevin Knapp, who was also a medic at our base in Santa Fe is the assistant team commander for New Mexico DMAT.
Um, so I had a phone call with him like almost a decade ago and he was like, yeah, you should put in for our team whenever we like open hiring again.
The time is like pretty convoluted for like how to get in on the team.
Um, so it was like years later that I finally got assigned to the, to the DMAT program in general.
At that time I was on contract in Seattle, like doing a travel nursing contract.
So I got assigned to like the Washington state team.
And then when I finally finished my orientation, I was on a contract in Reno.
So they put me, they moved me to the California team and then when I moved back to New Mexico a few years ago, I finally made it to New Mexico one DMAT.
Wow.
So it was a little bit of a convoluted process.
I think now it's been a long process.
Yeah.
Now it's a little more streamlined, although there are some complications with like, um, yeah, like federal hiring at the moment.
Um, but it's a pretty cool program in that, um, we basically take call.
Our team is on call for two or three months every year.
And then when we're on call, if we get deployed, we just like pack up as a team and hop on a plane and go to wherever this disaster happens to be.
Um, so so far I've been out twice.
Um, one of them, I went to American Samoa a couple of years back, um, for like a COVID response.
Um, and then most recently I was in North Carolina for hurricane Helene this best fall.
So that is completely, um, unrelated to your trips to Ukraine and Gaza.
Unrelated.
Okay.
Yeah.
So the DMAT stuff is like, uh, here through a federal program.
So it's like a, it's like a normal job in that, like when I get deployed, uh, I get paid for it.
Um, but I've been interested in that general like disaster and humanitarian response field for a long time.
And through that interest is how I ended up both in Gaza and the couple of trips I've been over to Ukraine with.
Um, when I was younger, before I got really like vested in the healthcare space, like I would occasionally like travel and like do some volunteer work with like different like humanitarian projects.
I think like the first time I left the country when I was a kid, uh, I went to maybe in like seventh grade, I went to, um, Guatemala with like a church project that was basically someone years ago.
I had like gone to this little village and they put a well at the top of this mountain and every summer they would go back and like run the piping from the well to another village to like provide water to people.
And my brother had gone the year before me.
He was a couple of years older than me and he had a great time and he convinced me to go with him.
Yeah.
So we like sold donuts at church on Sundays for like six months, like raise money.
So we could like go on the strip with the church group.
Um, but that kind of like sparked an interest in like doing that kind of thing, like both like traveling and getting like four and eight.
Yeah.
Like getting out of the country, like putting yourself in a situation where like you have no idea what's going on.
Uh, and also like finding a way to like give back.
Yeah.
And then like, as I got older and like, was a medic and a nurse, like I eventually realized that I could do both.
Like I could do that kind of like international travel and help and also like work in my field.
Yeah.
Um, so I've done a lot of different projects over the years.
Um, yeah, like working in healthcare overseas and there's kind of like by chance it kind of evolved into like more.
Like high risk in like conflict stuff.
I wasn't really by design.
Um, it just sort of like happened that I was like, um, working for a nonprofit that like, they also worked in that space and they.
Yeah.
Kind of included me on some of their projects that kind of pushed me in that direction.
Oh, cool.
Yeah.
Um, so back up a second.
So it's unrelated, but kind of related to your trips to Ukraine and Gaza.
How did you, so these are just like you found people along your travels or knowing people within DMAT that kind of do this other.
Yeah, not necessarily within DMAT, but like in that, like the community of like, uh, medical providers who like work overseas is like fairly small and it's kind of segmented.
There's like a lot of folks who like work in disaster response.
There's another like group of folks who work in like in the humanitarian response.
And then there's like a smaller group over here that works like in like the more high risk settings, the overlap between them.
Like it kind of varies.
You know, there's some people who like.
Shraddled two or three of those.
Um, but I've been kind of like exploring opportunities in like all of those spaces for awhile.
Um, so it's kind of, I guess at this point, like I have a fairly well-established network.
Um, so that when something comes up, like I often like am in the loop on like who is putting a roster together to get a team there and what they're doing.
Um, so yeah, it took me a long time to like get into that field.
Like, uh, like you, like for people who are like interested in like pursuing that type of work, a lot of like stuff, a lot of opportunities are available where you kind of like pay to volunteer.
Like you pay your own way.
Um, to get that experience.
But then once you have done that a couple of times, then you like know people in the field and they reach out to you and then, then like the next step would be to like find projects that are funded where you can actually get your travel paid for or stipend or maybe even like make some money off of it.
That kind of goes back to like what we were talking about getting into flight, right?
You have to still be like a cool person.
Like you have to work well with other people.
Totally.
You have to know your shit.
Yeah, for sure.
Especially for like more committing things, things that are like maybe considered to be a little more dangerous.
Like you don't really know like how you're going to do in that setting until you're there, but you sort of have to like prove to someone that like you're at least competent in like the medical side that you're doing.
And then you're like, you get along with people and then you're like open to things being a little like unknown.
Yeah.
And then you like try something a little more challenging.
That goes well.
Yeah.
You just kind of like keep going.
No, I think that's so cool.
Um, if I, you know, were 10 years younger and didn't have as many responsibilities as I, as I do, I would, I would totally jump on that.
Yeah.
But I wanted to, I wanted to kind of, and this is cool segue, but like I wanted to get into more of what you have experienced overseas with.
You know, your trips to Gaza and Ukraine kind of, and specifically in how your experiences as a flight nurse and being a medic, um, have contributed to your success over there with, you know, whatever clinical aspects came up.
Yeah.
So the first time I went over to Ukraine was like right after the initial full scale invasion.
Um, and there was a nonprofit that I was working with at the time.
I wasn't working full time for them, but I had done some work with them before.
Um, so they brought me on to go over to Ukraine with them and we got tasked, um, as part of this like working group to help set up a medevac program to like move patients.
Initially it was like from Western Ukraine, like far away from the front from Western Ukraine across the border into Poland.
And then we coordinated with, uh, air medical assets, like in Europe to like fly them to other places to get their like reconstructive surgery done.
And then eventually that project kind of moved further East to where now they're rendezvousing with, um, like ambulance is coming from the frontline to pick up patients or picking up patients and like smaller facilities closer to the frontline and moving them back to
hospitals in Ukraine and then other people are taking them like further West.
Um, so my, I guess to answer your question, I guess my skillset initially was more of like, just like knowing how the system works.
Um, uh, yeah.
And kind of like working there, like in more of a coordination role to get this like project started.
Um, and then there was like a little bit of gap from the first time I went over to, I went over again last summer because I was doing my clinicals for in peace school.
So I kind of like put all my travel on hold for a bit.
Um, but when I'm back both last summer and then over the holidays recently, I was working just as a medic in that program.
So just transporting patients.
Um, so last summer I was there with a, another group called artisans rescue and they, um, just do like critical care ambulance transfers.
So we're like picking up patients from, uh, hospitals, not like super close to the frontline, but in that direction and bringing them back to like a big city.
Um, that's a little safer where they can like get their recovery from surgery secured on a neapro.
D in IPR.
Oh yeah.
Neapro.
Um, and then this last time I went back, um, was with a group called caddis.
They're a group, um, out of Berlin, another nonprofit, and they were working kind of in the same system, but they also work a little further East, like closer to the frontline.
So they have bases.
Um, yeah, like one up in Sumi, which is up North and the one is still the answer, which is like further East.
And we would pick up patients like a little bit further than bring them back either to rendezvous with crews to take them back to neapro or to take them all the way back to neapro.
Um, and in both of those situations, we were doing basically the same stuff we do here on the helicopter, just in an ambulance.
So we have like, we use the same vents.
We have like, uh, IV pumps.
We have like same, like similar, like, uh, pharmacologic capabilities.
Uh, it's just our, our patients are all almost all trauma.
So it's like slightly different patient set, whereas like here it's mostly medical.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
And then this next time I go back in a couple of weeks and I'll be working, um, again with a different group.
Um, but I'll be in a stabilization point or a stab point as they call it, which is basically like, uh, uh, an ER kind of in a, like a safe space removed from the frontline.
Where people are coming to you.
Yeah.
So they're generally transported to the stabilization point via like a military evac, like a Casa vac situation.
Um, so they're bringing to us, we'll stabilize them.
Uh, if there's surgeons there who can like do initial like damage control surgery, like airway management, chest tube type stuff, um, stop the bleed, then we will put them on ambulances to do the next leg of things.
Cool.
Yeah.
Are those, uh, facilities managed by local agencies or are they, or is there a lot of, are you seeing a lot of us soldiers and aid and medical personnel there?
Uh, it's mostly most of the healthcare facilities themselves are all Ukrainian.
Um, some of the stabilization points are staffed by international NGOs, um, non-governmental organizations.
The ones that they're getting all that funding cut from.
The ones from the U S that's a little bit.
Yeah, the U S ones, but to be fair, like most in that space, most of those facilities, most of those stabilization points don't get any kind of like funding from programs like USA or anything like that, because they are affiliated directly with military units.
So in that humanitarian space, there are like, um, some like overarching principles of like humanitarian aid.
And one of them is that you have to be impartial.
So you kind of like separate yourself from funding sources.
If you are tied to any kind of like.
Come back and unit.
So most of those, um, organizations that work in that space in particular, they, um, they don't get any like funding other than private donations.
Yeah.
But other groups that work like further away.
Um, some of them do get funding, whether like through the WHO or through like the country where their organization is based.
Sure.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's really cool, man.
That's I've always, you know, over the last whatever it's been like year, year and a half, two years since I've known you.
I've always been interested in hearing your, you're taking your stories from, from those, um, trips that you do.
Um, and it's very admirable, but also like, um, you know, we talked about a little bit about getting outside your comfort zone.
Like that's just gotta be some of the more, um, stressful situations, not being able to speak the language unless you are fluent in Ukrainian.
I'm not.
Um, busted.
I know you speak Spanish pretty well, but, um, so yeah, I mean, how, how do you feel like you deal with that?
Being able to do that job that you're familiar with that you've been doing for some amount of years in an environment that is completely foreign and you don't speak the language.
Yeah.
I think initially it was an unknown.
Like when I, when I first got into like doing medical stuff internationally or even like just traveling internationally, like I was got like a little bit nervous.
And then you like, you realize like, okay, even if I don't speak the language, I can like get around, like I can like feed myself and find some more safe to sleep.
Right.
And the next step is like, can you like do your like job in another setting?
And then you like figure out that, okay, okay.
It's like uncomfortable, but I can like do this.
And then there's other, then you like add like in a safety factor, like, can I still do this if it's like dangerous?
Like if it's like, you know, like about, and then if I'm like responsible for other people in the setting and then I kind of just like stepwise kind of have like discovered that like, like I don't, I don't suck at it.
Like I I'm okay in those settings.
So like, do you find, so like I think about this for myself a lot, right?
And it's, it's putting yourself in a situation where you're uncomfortable and seeing how you do.
Totally.
Or do you find it as like, okay, I'm going to try and like, know as much as I can about this particular place, this thing, this thing that I'm doing, and try and like buff up my knowledge about that and try and make myself as comfortable as possible.
Yeah, I think there's a little bit of both.
Yeah, I'm trying to think of like a good example.
Like, I definitely think there's part of me that is down to try something more challenging.
You know, like when the war in Gaza kicked off and there was like options to go over, like, I was like, yeah, I'm going to go, but it wasn't like, I'm going to go and thrive.
I'm ready for this.
Yeah, it wasn't like, I'm going to go and thrive in the setting.
Yeah.
But I was like, I'm going to go because it presents a challenge.
And I like, I am curious to know like how I do in that setting.
Yeah.
So where do you think, I'm just curious because like a lot of the stuff that I post about is, you know, about like mental fortitude and like, you know, mental toughness.
Where do you think that comes from for you?
Um, I mean, I think part of it is like, I mean, it inherits, you know, like, you know, mental toughness.
A little bit of a cop out, but like some people are like comfortable, like being uncomfortable and some people aren't.
And I've always like, I think I've always just had that.
I don't know if like that was necessarily something that like I intentionally cultivated.
Um, but on the preparation side, like you were asking about, I do, I do do a lot of things to like make that easier.
Like I have like pretty regimented, like routine, whether I'm like here or overseas that like helps me like stay calm and like, yeah, keep it under control.
Um, just accepting that there's going to be a lot of unknown.
And yeah, for sure.
And to be fair, like I think sometimes it's like easier being gone than it is being here.
Like there's a lot of things we have to do here.
Um.
But like there's been times overseas where you like don't have any say, yeah, you don't, you don't get to choose what you do.
Um, which makes it easier.
Um, easier in the sense that you can just do the thing.
Totally.
Rather than like needing approval.
Or like, or you don't have to put so much, you don't have to put any thought into it.
Like you might appreciate this.
I wear, I have like a little heart rate monitor, like a polar age, 10, whatever.
And I like every morning, like put it on and like sit for five minutes and get like my heart rate variability.
And it like gives me like a readiness score for the day.
So I'm like, yeah, I'm like an eight or nine I'm ready to go.
Or like, I didn't sleep well cause we floor a night and I'm like a three or four.
Um, but I've been tracking this data for a very long time.
Um, like maybe like maybe not a very long time, but for me, it feels like a long time, like three or four years now, I have like a heart rate variability and a baseline heart rate for like almost every morning of my life.
Um, and the highest numbers I've ever seen was when I was like over in Gaza.
And I think part of that is like, I didn't have any say in what we were doing.
Like I could wake up, eat, go to work, come home and sleep.
And like, I, yeah, like I didn't, I didn't have to worry about like, there was no, there's no money to be spent.
I didn't have to worry about like going to work, running late, buying things.
Finances.
Like I didn't even have like a lot of the time that it didn't have access to like communications back home.
So like it took a lot of that stuff away that like we tend to stress about here.
That's really interesting.
Actually, I find that very interesting because you know, we, in our culture, in our society, we're inundated with stimulus.
Yeah.
And we think it's normal.
And we think it's normal, right?
We don't even notice it.
Yeah.
But also like my lack of understanding of what it's like to be over in Gaza, right?
Like I've never been there.
No idea.
All I see is like, what's on the news.
And it occurs to me as like a war zone, right?
There's just shit happening all the time.
Gunfire bombs, you know, people dying.
Like it occurs to me from this outside perspective as like a really stressful over stimulating environment.
But also without all of the things like the traffic or like phone calls or whatever things are inundated with here.
Yeah.
So it's really, I find that very fascinating.
And I think it is a little more like nuance than that.
Like it is, it is loud.
Like it's never quiet there.
And the time when I was there, it was like, you know, things were blowing up all the time.
Yeah.
But it's different for, or it was different.
It's probably still is different for like, uh, an international team there that the like calling the combatant forces, like they are aware of our location versus like someone who lives there.
Like a, a Palestinian who lives there who like doesn't have that security protection.
So even though it is like arguably like loud and stressful and dangerous, um, we did the things we could to like assure our safety.
And like, after that, like everything was out of my control.
So like, there was no utility in thinking on it more.
Um, yeah.
It's crazy, man.
Yeah.
That's cool though.
I think I've been like using this like analogy since I've like come back from Ukraine the last time that like to try and like explain like how I ended up doing this kind of thing.
And I think I'm like describing as like a Venn diagram, like when there's something that happens in the world, like something like a conflict or disaster, there's like a lot of people who want to go.
Like a lot of people want to help, but a very small group of that chunk, like have a skillset and demeanor and like.
The like stability back home to actually go and like make it work.
And there are a lot of people that do have the capability to go like do something useful, but they don't want to go where they're not comfortable with the risk.
And like the overlap between them is like maybe quite small.
Um, and I've kind of just by chance, like discovered that, like I fit in that, like the little overlap in that Venn diagram.
And like another factor that like really helps is that like both jobs back here in the US have been amazingly flexible with me.
Yeah.
Like one thing that holds up a lot of people from doing this kind of stuff is like telling your job, you want to leave for like two months to go somewhere and like not be in touch.
It's like kind of a hard mill for almost every other job situation.
Yeah.
But I've been super lucky that like both like the flight program and the hospital, they are very supportive.
So they're like down to let me go.
Yeah, that's cool.
Yeah.
I find it very cool that you've been able to kind of create your, your world in that sense, right?
Being able to have that flexibility that you want.
Yeah.
And then do these kind of extreme and awesome things.
Thanks.
So yeah, appreciate that.
It's pretty cool.
Yeah.
I had some other questions and I totally forgot them.
That's totally fine.
Well, if we think of them, we can do this again sometime.
Yeah.
This was really cool.
Thanks for sharing your thoughts and stuff.
For sure.
Thanks for coming on.
Yeah, man.
I always enjoy learning stuff from you.
So.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
But real quick, before we get going, just a couple of shout outs.
First is to the St. Fisher Church of Evidence Based Medicine.
If you haven't seen their page, definitely go check it out.
We used to also give a shout out to the Pragmatic Paramedics.
I don't think they're active anymore, but definitely take a look at their back episodes.
It's a good podcast.
And then lastly, shout out to my friend, Josh Pittman and his friend, Kevin Pons.
They're the ones who put the music together.
Thanks for watching.